en el vídeo pasado empezamos a platicar
de este problema de la caja cuando
cortamos las esquinas lo clavamos y
obteníamos un recipiente y queríamos
maximizar el volumen hicimos una gráfica
en la calculadora y pues así visualmente
aproximamos que más o menos para x igual
a 3.93 tendríamos un valor máximo de más
o menos 1000 56.29 para el volumen lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
resolver este problema ahora sí con
herramientas de cálculo y comparar los
dos resultados entonces aquí ya tenemos
el volumen expresado en términos de x
pero lo primero que voy a hacer es
desarrollar esto un poquito para que sea
más fácil de elevarlo sin tener que
utilizar regla del producto y así sino
una simple derivación de un polinomio
entonces déjame escribir por acabe de x
pd x y lo que voy a hacer es desarrollar
esto de acá entonces voy a poner la
equis y haciendo estos paréntesis de acá
me queda 20 x 30 son 600
600 luego 20 x menos 2x son menos 40 x
240 x menos 2 x 30 es menos 60 x 60 x y
luego menos 2 x x menos 2x que nos queda
más 4 x cuadrada y de esta forma el
volumen es igual a pues haber esté menos
40 x con este menos 60 x se hace menos
100 x va entonces estoy acá es un voy a
poner y así es un menos 100 x y
multiplicando por esta x de afuera nos
queda voy a recomendar si primero voy a
poner 4 x al cuadrado por x que es 4 x
al cubo y luego voy a poner x x menos
100 x que es menos 100 x cuadrada y
finalmente voy a poner más 600 600 x muy
bien esto de acá es la función del
volumen expresado en términos de x es un
polinomio es muy sencillito vamos a
derivar lo para ver que nos da entonces
la derivada de prima de x
es igual a 3 baja 3 por 4 12 12 x al
cuadrado menos dos bajas 2% es 200 200
el exponente baja en 1 más 600 ok esto
de aquí es la derivada entonces nos
gustaría ver cuando se hace cero o bien
cuando no está definida pero bueno aquí
siempre está definida verdad mira sobre
todo x está entre 0 y 10 entonces esto
de acá siempre son numeritos siempre
está muy bien definida
entonces para encontrar los puntos
críticos más bien tendríamos que ver
donde estoy acá se hace igual a cero
queremos ver dónde se anula la derivada
entonces nos gustaría encontrar las x es
para las cuales 12 x al cuadrado menos
200 x más 600 es igual a 0 y para
encontrar estas x es vamos a utilizar la
fórmula cuadrática digo o sea podría
intentar factorizar o lo que sea pero no
sé si me va a salir así que mejor
utilizamos dos en la duda utilizamos la
fórmula cuadrática entonces nos quedaría
x es igual a
a veces me ve y bueno este sabe este es
de 200 más menos más menos raíz cuadrada
raíz cuadrada debe cuadrada 200 al
cuadrado 2 2 x 2 64 y tiene que tener
cuatro ceros
entonces nos quedaría 40.000 40.000
menos 4 veces hace entonces 4 por 12 por
600 en cientos y todo eso dividido
dividido entre dos veces entre 24
entonces tenemos dos chances verdad que
x le toque más o que a x le toque menos
entonces vamos a hacer esos dos para ver
qué obtenemos entonces déjame bajar
tantito más o menos por ahí y entonces
vamos a sacar la calculadora
ok entonces la aprendemos aprendemos
entonces x es igual a 200 200 más la
raíz cuadrada raíz cuadrada le puse
second y x al cuadrado la raíz cuadrada
de 40.000 menos 4 por 12
a 600 ok esa es una primera opción bueno
hay que dividir entre 24 ahorita lo
divido entre 24 entonces la primera
opción es 12.74 si redondeamos a 74 va
entonces esta es una primera opción
12.74 esto es una equis y tenemos otra
posibilidad para equis que es en vez de
ponerle el más ponerle el menos sacamos
la calculadora otra vez lo que puedo
jalar lo que puse antes consecuente
enter entonces es lo mismo sólo que
ahora en vez de tener más tiene un menos
200 menos la raíz del bla bla bla cuánto
nos da y eso dividido entre 24
entonces es 3.92 37 3.92 vamos a
redondear lo a 3.92 vale 3.92 estas más
bien son aproximaciones aproximaciones
ok entonces 12.74 3.92 cuál de éstos nos
va a servir a pues ojo de hecho sólo uno
de éstos queda en la región que podemos
tener verdad o sea x igual a 3.92 es el
único que queda entre 0 y 10 x igual a
12 puntos 74 no se valen déjame tachar
lo que no se vale porque está fuera de
la región así que bueno si tenemos algún
máximo debe de corresponder a este de
acá
claro osea podríamos hacer la gráfica
verdad y ver que realmente esto de aquí
si parece un máximo pero en la duda es
mejor verificarlo de alguna forma
analítica y entonces vamos a ver que de
adeveras x igual a bueno aproximadamente
igual a 3.92 es el máximo utilizando el
criterio ahora de la segunda derivada
aquí está la primera derivada ya nada
más derivamos una vez más
efe doble prima de x es igual a
2 x 12 es 24 24 x menos 200 200 y el 600
ya al derivarse se hace cero entonces
qué sucede a ver x igual a 3.92 más o
menos es como 4 es más chiquito que 4
entonces esta expresión es más chiquita
que 4 por 24 pero cuatro por 24 es como
como 800 más o menos entonces que estar
acá es una cosa positiva verdad si estoy
haciendo las cosas bien
ah no perdón 4 por 24 no es 800 es como
80 entonces es 80 menos 200 más o menos
estoy aquí es una cosa negativa ok
entonces la segunda derivada es negativa
y eso que nos dice eso nos dice que las
funciones cóncava hacia abajo o sea que
tenemos una cosa más o menos de este
estilo
bueno aquí está la gráfica verdad ya
para que la pintó pero como la segunda
derivada es negativa la pendiente
empieza haciendo digamos muy positiva
luego empieza a ser menos positiva menos
positiva se hace cero en algún momento
piensa volverse negativa muy negativa y
luego es muy pronunciada entonces la
gráfica dvd x ve así y por tanto cuando
tenemos
que la derivada es igual a cero estamos
en este punto que en efecto es un máximo
entonces si x igual
bueno aproximadamente igual a 3.92 nos
da un valor máximo máximo y ya nada más
lo único que tenemos que hacer es ver
eso cuando nos daría en el volumen
verdad lo voy a escribir acá le voy a
poner b de 3.92 y déjame jalarla la
calculadora otra vez para ver más o
menos cuánto nos da aprendemos lo voy a
mover para acá para poder ver esta
expresión y este valor y nos queda 3.92
x 20 menos 2 x 3.92 y eso multiplicado
por 30 menos 2
3.92 déjame ver que haya copiado todo
bien 3.92 20 menos 220 menos dos por
tres puntos 92 y treinta menos dos por
tres puntos 92 ok aquí viene el redoble
de tambores y
enter nos quedan mil 56 punto 30000 56.3
excelente 1000 56.3 entonces ven o sea
nuestra aproximación visual nos dio un
volumen máximo de 1000 56.29 pero con
este método analítico alcanzamos un
poquito más de volumen verdad 1050 y 6.3
entonces eso estuvo súper padre ya
tenemos un valor mejor para x y ya claro
si quisiéramos realmente hacer este
corte tendríamos que contar acá 3.92
3.92 etcétera doblar y tendríamos
nuestra caja con volumen máximo hasta la
próxima